prophecy they were monomers pierre
cardin volver nervous Amazon or darling
I don't want Liliana or even now or even
90 other one dog scandal in the video
Mina dagwon and I'm Islamic I didn't
love it before where I wrote another in
[Music]
Nina is the oldest known woman taxes in
color it is an ancient South Indian
martial art the art of kawari expenses
for the use the force their hand six and
heavy swords and shields other yoni on a
girl Evelyn Lang and mother another body
another mom a month Achilles yes I'm not
that if you got a mother is preferable
see I happen if I did I couldn't mud yet
that's a kind of southern that when the
pillows enamel our Imam immoral okay
Kylie
never condone everybody charge but is
very cattlemen overriding this one month
later my Charley Wedemeyer okay our for
you well-known oligarchy but Canada both
the model every one dollar and lavender
anybody cotton le pas de concejal de
Guevara but Georgia law rock or download
quiero ver lo que tengo que ahora bottom
along another a large multiple remember
Taylor would be under African under get
a polar body water wonder what you've
all number say what I am raised every
piece right now remember taken over cool
in the water over there forget our alone
day recommended are you come on Adam
[Music]
[Music]
veinte face buddha do manga Akeno quasi
ago a ganache inspiron Olympia Volvo la
penita air - who can focus also let
business Telugu a decision coppola
Yolanda are two of the ten refugees
selected to be a part of the first
Olympic refugee team they will be
competing in judo they both fled
conflict in the Democratic Republic of
Congo and in a 2016 Olympics will
compete without country yo mama so tu
mas por que bueno pues Oquendo mid-tempo
meadow acid una vida por que hace
duplicated because so teleport sound and
evvamean good purple lunar lander bold
sought asylum in Brazil during the judo
World Championships in 2013 they haven't
seen their family since so forth on Sol
mama música l-dopa season on tour due to
funny sign in the mail
so Adagio remount su Familia ok toes
Gestalt honesty Tommy Gallo mimosa
pomegranate margin personal damage
partisan by competing in the Olympics
they are bringing their story to a
global audience
no Kakuta saw hysteresis yo [ __ ] is
advised us who my style bushka Spin
Master Jacques Vecchio
I cannot hand across on
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
my name is Lena Khalifa I'm the owner
and founder of cheap watches the first
office and studio for women in the
Middle East
I teach mix between tech wander boxing
and piers of defense techniques we also
have power women through seminars and
workshops like twisting violence sexual
harassment assault and of the women
empowerment I started in 2004 because
one of my friends got abused by her
father and brothers I was really upset
about their situation because I have a
background in martial arts I decided to
start giving lessons for women is
positive so domestic violence is their
high preference in Jordan in in violence
for women we have three placements you
don't see lots of girls walking the
street because of that
[Music]
she also is a safe place for women to
come and talk about their issues because
all the other girls have been mostly the
same experience the physical training
and mental training both are really
important so we start with talking to
the girls about their stories then we
move to the training we have trained and
empowered more than 12,000 women they're
fine joint I was facing like a lot of
verbal harassment I felt so weak because
I couldn't do anything about it since I
joined verbal harassment is less now
because I'm more confident now so when
walking and Street that shows like that
reflect to other people
[Music]
most girls here after the training they
feel that they can't stand up for
themselves it's about providing them
with the self-defense skills in from the
right and to have a voice in society I
actually did feel very guilty I had a
lot in a conflict for many years when I
first began the sport I felt that was
maybe going against my religion and it
really really used to tear me apart at
the same time I loved the sport and I
couldn't understand how that could be
wrong I realized that I was living a
double life you know one that was a nice
traditional girl at home and the other
where I succumbed to the gym and that
was another side of me
I remember the first time I walked into
the gym and for 18 years of age it was
quite a male-dominated environment but
none of that fazed me all I wanted to do
was participate in the sport multi
originally was designed as a warfare art
by the Kai's they used to use it to
defend their country it's known as the
art of eight limbs it's full speed full
pace full power and it's one of the
hardest sport in the world so it can be
quite intimidating I actually began my
sport training with Bill he actually
become like like a father figure to me
he took me under his wing at the same
time he puts on his coach hat he means
business I can't come up with excuses I
can't moan about them in pain or I'm
having a bad day when you're in training
mode you're in training ah the fact that
I come from an additional Muslim
background it's quite unusual to pursue
a sport such as mortai I was afraid that
my family might tell me sport or them I
remember coming home one day and my
father looked at me you said to me why
do we have a box I at that point I was
so frightened that the split would be
taken away from me and run up to my room
I had one trophy I hid that because I
thought that's the one key that gave it
a way down might be doing box Lizzy I
decided to tell them and I bought my
father down to the gym to reassure him
that all I was doing was exercising some
discipline in my life rather than been
out on the street gain involved with
things that I shouldn't be just knowing
that they know what I'm doing in my
spare time that's enough for me to
continue and make them proud
I don't want to walk away sitting in the
changing room crying my eyes out
thinking I could have done better or
actually I had it in me to win that
fight but I gave up
[Applause]
just me because forget about how coaches
forget about her supporters it's all
about what I can do in these ten minutes
of my life
[Applause]
you don't really have time for nerves
all you're thinking about is your neck
strike your strategy is it working is it
not am i hurting my opponent am i
winning the fight or what do I need to
change for you so is tactical obviously
you get caught with a nasty short you're
trying to phase that out very quickly
and get back onto your game plan
[Applause]
Oh
[Applause]
[Applause]
to win a fight is one of the most
amazing feeling in the world
it just reassures you that all that hard
work all that sacrifice everything that
everyone around you the team around you
the nutritionist your training partners
all those nights training aspiring going
home with bruises all that is worthwhile
talent along is not enough it's all
about sacrifice is all about being
dedicated and it's never the end until
you give up
[Music]